The jogan Experience yeah when I first
moved to New York I was 24 and I [__]
a girl that was like 37 oh [__] and that
was aw that's a leap son that was yeah
yeah I only I only got to [__] her once
which is you know you didn't do a great
job but I did eat her [__] for I got
that was my first encounter with a
squirter we [__] conratulations thanks
man that's amazing thanks man I are you
sure it's real I mean you're you sure
she wasn't peeing all over you she it
was clear I thought about saying how
often do you pee and it's not clear
clear and it's not clear yeah quite a
bit I'm not very hydrated okay that's
not
good and you got to think you also got
it's not like you know you got to
rationalize if someone has so much piss
in them that they piss while you're
[__] them right they're probably
hydrated that's true she didn't seem
hydrated she was a hefty gal she was you
know prob very hydrated you think so I
don't know I don't know she didn't see I
don't know what it is she drank a lot
you they do say it's real but then they
also say it's just pee I feel like it's
real I've thought about this a lot it's
sort of like Jesus if you believe in it
right right for you make your own thing
faith is Beautiful Joe and I believe
it's really I believe it's another thing
it doesn't taste like piss how do you
know what piss tastes like how well you
could guess clear piss I guess I haven't
tast really I guess it doesn't smell
Elite Ultra
Runner guess just running with a water
bladder
on sucking in all that water all right
not bad uh it feels cool either way even
though even if you as long as you you're
right it's pure faith and I choose I
choose to believe it's not piss you know
Jamie what is it has it definitively
been addressed by science wait a minute
have you encountered squirters though
Jamie yeah i' well yes but Jamie I want
I would like to Google I would like you
to Google what is squirting and is it
really just pee I think you're going to
find a I think you're going to find a
divided scholarship on the
map I think there's a lot of people that
have a vested interest believe they were
a pissed on big piss big squirt big piss
money is throwing off the data
conclusions the present data based on
ultrasonographic bladder monitoring and
biochemical analysis indicates that
squirting is essentially the involuntary
emission of urine ESS during sexual
activity although a marginal
contribution of prostatic secretions to
the emitted flu and often it exists so
that's like [__] juice well that's like
a little how to say [__] juice this
says Doctor theorize squirting is a form
of stress incontinence isn't it kind of
interesting though that we have like you
couldn't say [__] juice yeah like if
you if you're publishing a scientific
paper we must have another word for this
term that's acceptable for everyone to
discuss the exact same goddamn thing
whatever py juice it's [__] juice so
you're saying we should in the you know
medical journals that say [__] juice
well why this is what I understand why
is there piure of ayser if it's the same
thing is that some some ladies but if
it's the same thing if it's the same
thing why is [__] juice offensive and
why is that other long ass word
inoffensive when they're literally just
sounds you make so I know what you're
talking about yeah that's all it is I I
agree with you I mean now we're talking
about what what is language you know
what I mean it's like a different word
specifically with certain things like
[__] juice [__] ju I think you'd have
to go at least I think maybe vaginal
juice if you were talking to a doctor
and the doctor was saying you got a
problem with your [__] juice like this
doctor's trying to [__] me I got to get
out of there I got to get out of here
was he even wearing gloves why why did
he smell like's like uh oh yeah your
your pH is [__]
up time for a little test yeah he's
talking about your [__] that's not good
nope uh yeah your [__] all [__]
up ah yeah you absolutely need you got
what I like to call Rusty [__] squir is
related to glands in the urethal sponge
which is embedded in the vaginal walls
along the sides of the urethra these
glands called Skin glands are part of
the urination process researchers have
long debated whether squirting liquid
contains P or if it's a unique substance
and studies where researchers performed
a chemical analysis of squirting fluid
they found chemicals that are also in
urine but here's the thing I want to
know but hold on a second chemical
analysis of squirting liquid they per
researchers performed a chemical
analysis of squirting liquid and how
does one acquire such squirting liquid
what scientific studies are you finger
banging ladies until they squirt all
over the place pleasure five women to
find out oh my God they asked a man to
pleasure five women they paid a guy for
that's got to feel awesome to be that
guy what did he do oh was in
Japan it's all coming full circle baby
all roads lead to
Japan that Mak of the r now I'm not
shocked now of course they did some guy
just bowing guy probably came in with a
briefcase two of the women with in their
30s two in their 40s and one was in
their 50s and all of them said they had
previously squirted in past sexual
encounters let's [__] go unlike
vaginal lubrication where a person's
vagina secretes a white and milky fluid
when they're aroused squirting involves
a clear and odorless fluid
AKA squirt [__] juice Squirting can
happen before during after an orgasm and
has geyser likee quality sex educator
Marlo Renee Stewart previously told
Cosmopolitan imagine if you're a lady
and you're a scorting expert right
that's a freak hell yeah you know she
knows how to Fu do tricks with her [__]
it happen Okay doctors examine the urine
from each woman's bladder during using a
urethal c catheter excuse me they
injected them with 50 mL of blue dye
saline solution in another room women
receive manual pen from a male subject
the doctor recruited recruited they're
like we need the finest finger popper in
the land the finest in the Shogun
it I have been fingering in the
mountains for days yeah some guy in the
mountains just doing this they
instructed the man to use his fingers
and penis and penis in a way to
facilitate squirting let me just say
these gals sound cool W this guy banged
them that's awesome fingers and penis
this is crazy he banged them for the
international Journal of
Urology that is so scientific finger
popping so what does it find each of the
five women Square the doctors saw blue
liquid come out of their genital areas
in videos that capture the experiment
their finding suggest the liquid women
produce when they squirt comes at least
in part from the bladder okay the
urologist wrote in their August 24 paper
published in the international Journal
of Urology this is so wild they paid a
guy to [__] the piss out of these girls
like literally he [__] the piss out of
them he literally [__] the piss out of
that's awesome and he was like you
thought I'd never amount to anything
that is wild okay here's okay ready to
hear about this okay it has piss in it
right but they have something else in
there too right so whatever [__] juice
they couldn't
say style of [__] juice the vagina as
it comes squirting out like a geyser
this proba detectable amounts it's
probably like steroids they find in
supplements like acdal steroids you
could find it ex absolutely so here's
what I posit even even if it starts as
piss water you add Kool-Aid to it
Kool-Aid powder now it's Kool-Aid so the
piss you add special little concentrated
[__] juice in there okay now it's
squirt all right
piss maybe a couple maybe a couple of
those I'm not scared of piss but let's
just be honest about what it is like I
that wouldn't bother me if someone peed
on me agree to disagree it's not that
big a deal I wouldn't want I guess if it
was very clear pit I guess if it was
like the squirt I found look if you're
really into a girl and you're having sex
that she accidentally pees on you are
you going to stop you know what I
actually oh no well have I busted yet no
no let it go let it go this [__] body
fluid I will say
actually maybe I have encountered some
tough
squirt now that I'm thinking about it
tough squirt that should be the name of
your next special tough
squirt tough squirt oh my god dude I
have now that we're thinking about it it
pro and she was not
and it was like you know when when you
crack open crabs and it has that little
yellow [__] in there that was left on
the [__] sheets yeah and it was so
rank I couldn't get hard
afterwards I ate her [__] and then I I
got like my literally my dick and oh man
God oh my God and she even was like damn
I need to drink more water did she blast
on you yeah dude in the mouth everywhere
very much so oh my God
I'm just picturing this the amount of
urine depends on when the person peed
last and how hydrated they are New York
University sex researcher Zanna
vangelova told mindbody green that
sounds like that's a hot name too I bet
she's hot too she sounds like the evil
lady we were talking about ear prob
perfect features talking about piss
angular big ass tits yeah yeah all right
how Wild is that Japanese study though
but that's the kind of science you can
get away with if you're living in a
country that's more open-minded yeah but
then again they they [__] blur out
the genitals that's the [__] tradeoff
I know that's what's Wild but I'll take
both yeah the the other thing is like
the weird thing is like that this guy
how did he get that job did he have to
audition like how do you know he wasn't
fall apart it says he was recruited
right but how do they know he was going
to get hard someone was sent out maybe
one of the doctors was a freak yeah they
found this dude you got to find the best
they were that sounds also like the plot
this study probably was recorded and put
out with blur genitals this sounds like
the plot of a Japanese story could be a
comedy movie if we had a time machine
yeah yeah if we could no if we could
bring it back to like 1994 when you can
make a movie like this and not go to
jail and not get cancelled like we tried
to make this movie today the outrage
would be off the charts the squirt
doctor you think he couldn't make the
squirt doctor no chance you this this
guy you're going to have him finger bang
these women and [__] the [__] out of
them all five of them and hiring this
guy to come in and sling dick it would
probably have to be a lesbian thing and
you find out that these women are just
pissing all over him I don't know and
all their dreams are shattered cuz they
thought they were squirters they were
the rare Hot squirter but meanwhile they
just peeing on guys and now these guys
are like leaking that to the world gets
on the internet everybody knows you're
just peeing on folks you're just peeing
on folks what if the guy was hot and and
it's for
women real piece of ass I'm sure he's
probably hot they wouldn't Force the
women to I mean if they forced the women
to have sex with some gross guy oh I
made a nice discovery just now what I
found a video of the test no yeah put it
up the actual test yeah let's go put it
up I love learning dude I love science
there
whoa no this can't be the [__] actual
test see this I I don't know if the
sound or not well the audience can't see
this right what the [__] is this yo what
am I looking at so that's his fingers in
her [__] from the back those are ass
cheeks and this is the blue blue liquid
so there's blue liquid everywhere yo
that's him [__] oh you see your
tits this blue liquid coming out oh my
God first of all that's not my has not
been my experience it's dribbling out
look at then there's someone else under
there catching it that's what's crazy
and look at those Untamed Asian
bushes it looks like the other oh wow oh
my God now that now we're talking that's
what I that's oh my God look at her go
what the [__] look they're collecting it
someone fig collecting this girl got it
trimmed though oh my God this is so wild
you can tell it's not porn though cuz
it's not blurred you're right this is
[__] science science I'm not hard all
they should do that for all porn from
Japan just making science
experiments the music's nice touch the
yeah the music's relxing this is insane
dude this man is going after it can we
see hisis I don't think they'll let you
see his penis oh wow that's I mean she's
basically pissing out blue Kool-Aid look
at that that is crazy she's peeing she's
just peeing but the one girl the one was
squirting you see that geyser that
[__] pop she was peeing I don't know
man that's what girls do if they were
peeing I'm backing if they had a pee and
just laid on their back and peed it
would squirt up in the air yeah I guess
you're right yeah of course I'm right
Jesus Christ what are you talking about
I want to believe I know you do I know
you do it's
fascinating to believe brother I'm just
really obsessed with this [__]
Japanese
the guy Department of Urology that did
this that's what's fascinating I want
the guy they got this run up the flag
pole you should get the guy in here
maybe but but those [__] doctors they
ran up the flag pole to like who and
they were like yeah let's go let's go
have a got a little extra money in the
[__] that feels like the the B
they're going to be under budget unless
they have one more study and they let
one guy be like what if we checked out
if squirt is pissed they're like
beautiful I wonder how much money they
spent to check out if squirt is pissed
Jamie will you send me that article this
needs further investigation still
investigating this right now five send
me will you please like just text me
that article yes so there's five women
there's one guy he only [__] them once
in an afternoon who knows he's probably
banging them like for months yeah do you
think they kept in touch afterwards they
have money they probably put together
like a a whole series of bangs wow you
can't just count on one it's like you're
filming a special want a few shows yeah
yeah yeah yeah I also like they
recruited him but they had to recruit
good squirters too reliable squirters
reliable girls who had squirted multiple
times but some women pee if they laugh
true I mean that's kind of probably
similar the involuntary reaction of yeah
cuz do they squirt when they're
orgasming or they just squirt in the
middle of intercourse no no orgasm only
yeah is that what they tell you I I've
listen like I said I've been very
upfront with having disgusting squirt in
my mouth why would I start lying now
Joe i' I've established my Bon of
feeds oh my God good point Thank you
very good
point oh so you've never encountered or
you have no I've never encountered wow
no interesting yeah well it wasn't a
thing when I was a kid man you think
it's learned behavior I think it came
about because of porn interesting I mean
I'm sure let me be clear I'm sure it was
happening for porn but it was never like
a thing that was discussed
right